SO TAKE THREE STEPS BACK AND
ASSESS WHAT YOU'VE JUST HEARD.
FEDERAL AGENTS ARE DUMPING
THOUSANDS OF ILLEGAL ALIENS AT
BUS STATIONS AND THEN SIMPLY
WALKING AWAY.
THEY DON'T WANT TO DO IT, THEY
HAVE NO CHOICE.
CONGRESS WON'T HELP THEM.
OUR SYSTEM IS IN TOTAL COLLAPSE.
NOBODY'S EVEN TRYING TO PROTECT
YOU OR OUR COUNTRY.
KIRSTEN GILLIBRAND IS A U.S.
SENATOR AND A DEMOCRATIC
PRESIDENT CANDIDATE.
SHE THINKS WHAT IS HAPPENING IS
JUST FINE.
ON SUNDAY, SHE WENT ON
TELEVISION TO EXPLAIN THAT WE
HAVE NO RIGHT TO DETAIN ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS.
INSTEAD, THEY SHOULD BE RELEASED
DIRECTLY INTO OUR COUNTRY.
>> BUT YOU'RE WITH THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION DID IN TERMS OF
KEEPING FAMILIES TOGETHER OR
KEEPING THEM TOGETHER FOR A
LONGER PERIOD OF TIME AND
ATTENTION?
>> AS PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, I WOULDN'T USE
THE DETENTION SYSTEM AT ALL.
>> HOMELAND SECURITY IS SEEN
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
ARE CROSSING THE BORDER AND THEY
NEED TO GO SOMEWHERE BEFORE AT
THEIR ASYLUM CLAIMS ARE ACTUALLY
HURT.
WHAT WOULD YOU DO WITH THEM?
>> THEY DON'T NEED TO BE
INCARCERATED.
IF THEY ARE GIVEN A LAWYER AND
GIVEN A PROCESS, THEY WILL
FOLLOW IT.
>> Tucker: IT GOES WITHOUT
SAYING THAT FUNCTIONING
SOCIETIES DON'T OPERATE LIKE
THIS.
COUNTRIES THAT CARE ABOUT THEIR
PEOPLE ENFORCE THEIR OWN LAWS.
OUR LEADERS ARE DECADENT AND
NARCISSISTIC.
THEY CARE ONLY ABOUT THEMSELVES.
THEY WILL NEVER DEFEND OUR
NATION.
THAT'S OBVIOUS, AND THE REST OF
THE WORLD KNOWS IT.
THE AMERICAN PINATA HAS BEEN
GETTING PUMMELED FOR DECADES AND
NOW IT HAS FINALLY COME APART.
OUR NATIONAL WEALTH IS UP FOR
GRABS BY WHOEVER GETS HERE
FIRST.
AND THEY ARE COMING.
OVER JUST THE PAST YEAR, 1% OF
THE ENTIRE POPULATION OF THE
NATION OF GUATEMALA HAS MOVED TO
THE UNITED STATES.
"WALL STREET JOURNAL" PIECE LAST
MONTH DECIDES THE PLATE OF THAT
COUNTRY'S VILLAGES.
SOME OF THEM ARE LITERALLY
REPOPULATING AS PEOPLE STREAM
NORTH TO AMERICA'S GENEROUS
WELFARE STATE.
MEANWHILE IN A STUDY FOR THE
FEDERATION FOR AMERICAN
IMMIGRATION REFORM GIVEN
EXCLUSIVELY TO THE SHOW SHOWS
THE SCALE ON WHICH THE
UNITED STATES IS BEING PLUNDERE
PLUNDERED.
EVERY YEAR FOREIGN-BORN WORKERS
SEND ABOUT $150 BILLION IN
REMITTANCES TO THEIR FRIENDS AND
FAMILY OVERSEAS.
THAT'S MORE THAN THE GDP OF 18
AMERICAN STATES.
ILLEGAL ALIENS ALONE ARE
ADMITTING $28 BILLION.
THAT'S $20 BILLION LEAVING THIS
COUNTRY GOING ABROAD EVERY YEAR
FROM PEOPLE WHO DON'T EVEN HAVE
THE LEGAL RIGHT TO WORK HERE IN
THE FIRST PLACE, BUT ARE, AND
ARE BENEFITING OF COURSE FROM
ALL THE EXTRAS, CAREFREE
EDUCATION, HOUSING, FOOD STAMPS,
WHO KNOWS WHAT ELSE.
AT THE REMITTANCES ARE NOT
TAXED.
IN THE CASE OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS WORKING UNDER THE
TABLE, THEIR ORIGINAL EARNINGS
HAVE NEVER BEEN TAXED EITHER.
SO THIS IS A DISASTER, BUT IT'S
NOT A NATURAL DISASTER.
WE COULD HAVE PREVENTED IT WITH
A WALL, MANDATORY E-VERIFY,